Andrew is the hardest working man I've
ever met even with the lifestyle he
lives now and as fun as it looks and it
is fun even if we are in a luxury hotel
in the south of France where you're
paying ten thousand dollars per room
Andrew will be up at seven o'clock in
that hotel gym he'll message me at 8 30
I'll wake up next to God knows who
whiskey spilled all over the desk but
again that inspires me and to be like
emergency meeting in my room emergency
meeting you always say that so I'll go
to his room what's the emergency room
and he'll bring up tiny issues with the
business you know I could have slept on
quite happily but again it's like me
doing the exercise when he won it pushes
me to be a better person and Andrew will
happily work 15 16 hours a day and then
go out and spend four or five hours
having fun and blowing loads of money it
doesn't come from the sky it's not magic
we're not trust fun kids we didn't win
the lottery he is the hardest working
man I have ever met